This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you're a longtime 99% invisible listener, Avery Truffleman needs no introduction. And all you need to hear right now is this. There is a new season of Articles of Interest. Get excited. But for those who aren't familiar, I guarantee if you enjoy 99PI, then Articles of Interest is for you. It's a spinoff show that Avery created when she worked here, but it's now completely independent.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是Roman Mars。如果你是《99% Invisible》的老听众，Avery Truffleman就不需要介绍了。你现在只需要听这个：Articles of Interest有新一季了。期待一下吧。但对于那些不熟悉的人，我保证如果你喜欢《99PI》，那么Articles of Interest也一定适合你。这是一个衍生节目，是Avery在这里工作时创作的，但现在已经完全独立了。
It is a brilliant and compelling exploration about what we wear. Pockets, plaid, sunglasses, zippers. There's a fascinating story behind all of them. The latest season is called gear. It's about the surprising intersection of the military and the outdoor goods industry. Brands that you wouldn't expect like R.E.I., Patagonia, L.L. Bean, and Eddie Bauer, all have their roots in military surplus and design. In this new season, over seven chapters, Avery Explorers,
这是一次关于我们穿着什么的精彩而引人入胜的探索。口袋、格子呢、太阳镜、拉链。它们背后都有迷人的故事。最新一季叫“装备”（Gear）。它讲述了军事和户外用品行业之间令人惊讶的交集。你意想不到的品牌，如R.E.I.、Patagonia、L.L. Bean和Eddie Bauer，它们的根源都在军事剩余物资和设计中。在这一新季的七个章节中，Avery将探索，
these two industries shaped so much of our attitudes about nature and about our nation. Today, we are presenting the very first chapter of gear. And after you listen, go find articles of interest in your podcast app and hit the subscribe button. You are going to love it. Now, do not infuriate me and make me repeat myself. Do you understand me? Chapter one. Let me start with the basics, the most basic basics, cackeys, button downs, crisp white t-shirts.
这两个行业如何塑造了我们对自然和国家的许多态度。今天，我们将呈现“装备”的第一章。听完之后，去你的播客应用里找到Articles of Interest并点击订阅按钮。你会爱上它的。现在，别惹我生气，让我重复一遍。你明白我的意思吗？第一章。让我从基础开始，最基础的基础，卡其裤、扣领衬衫、清爽的白T恤。
These are all clothes that one goes to buy at Buck Mason. And so if we think about what is a classic closet and what belongs within it, then our job as a brand is to make the best version of those archetypes. Buck Mason was founded in 2013 and has positioned itself to be a, a purveyor of classic, cool clothes that are so timeless they almost allude description. And I was in their Los Angeles headquarters with Kyle Fitzgibbons. I am chief design and creative officer. Kyle told me that this brand's whole classic cool vision was inspired by vintage clothes, which makes sense. I mean, clothes are considered classic for a reason.
这些都是人们去Buck Mason购买的衣服。所以，如果我们思考什么是经典衣橱，什么属于其中，那么我们作为一个品牌的任务就是制作这些原型的最佳版本。Buck Mason成立于2013年，定位为经典、酷炫服装的供应商，这些服装永恒到几乎无法描述。我和Kyle Fitzgibbons在他们洛杉矶的总部。我是首席设计和创意官。Kyle告诉我，这个品牌整个经典酷炫的愿景灵感来自于复古服装，这很有道理。我的意思是，衣服被称为经典是有原因的。
Kyle told me they keep a whole stockpile of vintage clothes and storage, but they brought out just a little section to show me. Wait, oh, you're really not fucking around. I was led into a conference room that was dripping with old clothes. It was in piles on the table. It was dangling from racks. It was hanging from the walls. The actual collection is a lot bigger than this.
Kyle告诉我，他们保留了一大批复古服装库存，但他们只拿出一小部分给我看。等等，哦，你真的不是在开玩笑。我被带进了一个挂满旧衣服的会议室。桌子上堆着，架子上挂着，墙上悬着。实际的收藏比这大得多。
These clothes are the stuff of Kyle's work. This is what he and the other designers play with and take a part on a daily basis. They're copying elements of these classic old clothes. down to the tiny details. Stitch color, fabric finish, trim finish, things like that. Quite literally, they're copying the details. So what we'll do is, like, let's say, one of the designers is making this pant.
这些衣服是Kyle工作的内容。这就是他和设计师们每天把玩和拆解的东西。他们正在复制这些经典旧衣服的元素，细致到微小的细节。缝线颜色、面料处理、饰边处理等等。确实，他们是在复制细节。所以我们会做的是，比如，假设其中一位设计师正在制作这条裤子。
What they'll do is they'll get a magnifying glass and they'll count the stitches per inch on an out seam or a side seam or a fly and then replicate that. Replicating tiny details as a way of grafting a little character onto a new piece of clothing. To Kyle, this is about giving a garment a sense of soul. a feeling like it has a life to it. But almost all of these classic, timeless garments
他们会拿一个放大镜，数一数外缝或侧缝或门襟上的每英寸针数，然后复制它。复制微小的细节是一种将一点个性嫁接到新衣服上的方式。对Kyle来说，这是为了赋予服装一种灵魂感。一种它有生命的感觉。但几乎所有这些经典、永恒的服装
shared a very similar past life. All of these garments that had been collected for me in this conference room were all old military surplus clothes. If you pick things off of this wall, there's almost every archetype for every modern piece of clothing. Like what? What are we seeing? I see flight jackets. flight jackets, bomber jackets,
都有着非常相似的前世。在这个会议室里为我收集的所有这些服装，都是旧的军事剩余服装。如果你从这面墙上拿东西，几乎每一件现代服装都有对应的原型。比如什么？我们看到了什么？我看到了飞行夹克。飞行夹克，轰炸机夹克，
1950s and 60s automotive car culture jackets, every version of a field jacket, chore jackets that's all there. Almost all classic menswear is based on 20th century military. I think the majority of not all of the industry subconsciously acknowledges how this is the archive.
20世纪50年代和60年代的汽车文化夹克，各种版本的野战夹克，工装夹克，都在这里。几乎所有的经典男装都基于20世纪的军事装备。我认为大多数（如果不是全部）行业都在潜意识里承认这就是档案库。
You either acknowledge the fact that these spawn from military garments or you don't, but... But it's happening no matter what. I would, in fact, wager that almost every single garment and accessory I have ever reported on has had some connection to war. I have a few pairs of Korean War-era pants that I wear that are super comfortable. They got all the right pockets.
你要么承认这些源自军装的事实，要么不承认，但……无论如何，它都在发生。事实上，我敢打赌，我报道过的几乎每一件服装和配饰都与战争有某种联系。我有几条朝鲜战争时期的裤子，我穿起来非常舒服。它们有所有合适的口袋。
Everything's perfectly thought out. I'm like, yeah, there's a reason why Old Navy makes like a cheap imitation of these pants. And clothing's connection to war is not simply a matter of a situation. aesthetics. The United States military is involved in a very practical way in the creation of clothing itself. This is something that Alex Goulet realized, somewhat ironically, in his quest to become a more ethical shopper. If clothing is supposed to reflect your values, then what are my values? And where I think I ended up was that if you can buy something close by to you that was made by a neighbor. The level of transparency is the highest. For the last 10 years, Alex
一切都经过深思熟虑。我就想，是的，Old Navy制作这些裤子的廉价仿制品是有原因的。服装与战争的联系不仅仅是美学问题。美国军方在服装本身的创造中以一种非常实际的方式参与其中。这是Alex Goulet在寻求成为一名更合乎道德的购物者时，有些讽刺地意识到的事情。如果服装应该反映你的价值观，那么我的价值观是什么？我想我最终得出的结论是，如果你能买到附近邻居制作的东西。透明度是最高的。在过去的10年里，Alex
Goulet has only bought clothes that were made in the United States, with as fair labor practices as he can find. Nothing can be confirmed 100 percent, but for me, it's worked out really well, and I have a really healthy relationship with the things I wear. And Alex is determined to help other Americans shop like he does. So can you tell me what this is? This is a book project called Crafted with Pride. It's a directory of Made in USA, clothing, footwear, and accessories. Crafted with Pride is a really cool resource. It's printed in yellow, like a phone book. There's 1,400 companies represented. Alex and his co-author organized this guidebook by product, so you could be like, I need a handbag, and then you could turn to the handbag page,
Goulet只购买在美国制造的衣服，并尽可能寻找公平的劳动实践。没有什么能百分之百确认，但对我来说，效果非常好，我和我穿的东西之间有着非常健康的关系。Alex决心帮助其他美国人像他一样购物。那么你能告诉我这是什么吗？这是一个名为“以自豪感制作”（Crafted with Pride）的书籍项目。它是美国制造的服装、鞋类和配饰的目录。“以自豪感制作”是一个非常酷的资源。它像电话簿一样印成黄色。有1400家公司入选。Alex和他的合著者按产品整理了这本指南，所以你可以说，我需要一个手提包，然后你可以翻到手提包那一页，
and there are a number of different American purse manufacturers. Granted, there are not many, but there are Some. Other products, however, are easier to find in these pages. Like, if you want a backpack, you're in luck. Gortex jackets, down jackets. This company makes all kayak and rafting gear. Most of the entries in this guide are from the outdoor industry in all its various forms. Tons of biking gear, a lot of hunting stuff. Is it because Americans are so hardcore and outdoorsy? Sure. But there's another reason why the outdoor industry still has a viable foothold manufacturing in the United States. Military contractors in the outdoor industry specifically have a pretty long history with
那里有许多不同的美国钱包制造商。当然，数量不多，但确实有一些。然而，其他产品在这些页面中更容易找到。比如，如果你想要一个背包，你很幸运。Gore-Tex夹克，羽绒服。这家公司生产所有的皮划艇和漂流装备。本指南中的大多数条目都来自各种形式的户外行业。大量的自行车装备，很多狩猎用品。是因为美国人太硬核、太喜欢户外活动了吗？当然。但户外行业在美国制造方面仍然拥有可行立足点的另一个原因是。户外行业的军事承包商特别与
working with the military. If you page through Alex's guide, you'll see a lot of these small American factories also provide to the military. Made in USA, the way it exists right now is in a lot of part due to military contracts. Thanks to the 1941 Barry Amendment, all clothes made for the United States military, have to be made in the United States. It makes sense, right? It's a matter of national security.
与军方合作有着相当长的历史。如果你翻阅Alex的指南，你会看到许多这些小型美国工厂也为军方提供服务。美国制造，以目前存在的方式，很大程度上归功于军事合同。多亏了1941年的《贝里修正案》（Barry Amendment），所有为美国军方制造的衣服都必须在美国制造。这很有道理，对吧？这是一个国家安全问题。
We can't have our army clothes made in, say, Vietnam or China because what if, say, we went to war with Vietnam or China. This is one of the last things that have been holding up American clothing manufacturing over the last couple of decades. Almost every other kind of clothing has moved its production overseas. It's not like the reason they're still manufacturing in the U.S., But it sounds like it kind of is the military and very compliance. Well, yeah, no, absolutely.
我们不能让我们的军装在越南或中国制造，因为如果我们和越南或中国开战怎么办。这是过去几十年来支撑美国服装制造业的最后几件事之一。几乎所有其他种类的服装都已将生产转移到海外。这并不是他们仍然在美国制造的原因，但听起来确实有点像是因为军事和合规性。嗯，是的，不，绝对是。
The only reason these things are made in U.S. is very compliance at this point in time. If you buy something that says made in the USA, its zippers could come from a factory that makes zippers for the military. Its buttons could come from a factory that makes buttons for the military. There's hardly a reason an American factory would make thread without the military. It's just embedded in American garments. So Alex feels very mixed about this. You know, it's sad that some of the more technical, interesting products in here were made for the military. There's definitely companies that have military contracts that we did not include that are, like, tactical gear that increases kill rates.
目前，这些东西在美国制造的唯一原因就是合规性。如果你买的东西上面写着美国制造，它的拉链可能来自一家为军方制造拉链的工厂。它的纽扣可能来自一家为军方制造纽扣的工厂。如果没有军方，美国工厂几乎没有理由制造线。它只是嵌入在美国服装中。所以Alex对此感到非常矛盾。你知道，令人难过的是，这里面一些更具技术性、更有趣的产品是为军方制造的。肯定有一些拥有军事合同的公司我们没有包括在内，比如增加杀伤率的战术装备。
And you're just like, okay, I don't know if I want that in the book. But, like, the military informs so much of what we do. I mean, the internet was invented by the military. You know, like name 30 products. Probably half of them were military inventions. And the contracts with the Department of Defense have been keeping manufacturers afloat so they can make all their other cool stuff.
你只会觉得，好吧，我不知道我是否想把那个放进书里。但是，军事确实影响了我们所做的大部分事情。我的意思是，互联网是军方发明的。你知道，列举30个产品。可能有一半是军事发明。而与国防部的合同一直让制造商维持生计，这样他们才能制造所有其他酷炫的东西。
You benefit from having the military there as your primary customer. And then these other smaller brands are also eating from that same trough. And that's especially true in outdoor industries because they tend to make super technical products. The military and the outdoor industry are interwoven.
你受益于拥有军方作为你的主要客户。然后这些其他较小的品牌也在同一个槽里吃食。在户外行业尤其如此，因为他们倾向于制造超技术性的产品。军事和户外行业是交织在一起的。
The outdoor industry had a huge role in forming how the United States military looks and the military in turn came to shape
户外行业在塑造美国军方的外观方面发挥了巨大作用，而军方反过来又塑造了
the outdoor industry. Military is just a crazy section of the world that like I don't think about as much. Same.
户外行业。军事只是世界上一个疯狂的部分，我不太去想它。我也是。
I also used to not think about the military. I mean, I thought about it and that I was against it categorically
我也曾经不去想军事。我的意思是，我考虑过它，而且我从根本上反对它
as an institution but I didn't like know any veterans or active duty soldiers for most of my life, basically, until I started working on this series. And if you're listening to this, and you are a soldier or a veteran, I can just feel you rolling your eyes at this classically clueless civilian.
作为一个机构，但在我生命的大部分时间里，我基本上不认识任何退伍军人或现役士兵，直到我开始制作这个系列。如果你正在听这个，而你是一名士兵或退伍军人，我能感觉到你在对这个经典无知的平民翻白眼。
I know. We live in this moment in history where there's a gaping rift between this country's military and this country's civilians. There's even a term for it, like college students take courses on the military civilian divide, and it's gotten to the very practical nightmare where, as I write this, President Trump is ordering Marines and the National Guard into American cities to detain American citizens.
我知道。我们生活在历史的这一刻，这个国家的军队和这个国家的平民之间存在着巨大的裂痕。甚至有一个术语，比如大学生学习关于军民分歧的课程，它已经演变成了一个非常实际的噩梦，在我写这篇文章时，特朗普总统正在命令海军陆战队和国民警卫队进入美国城市拘留美国公民。
We've been pitted against each other. And yet, oddly enough, American soldiers and American civilians have never been more intertwined than we both are now in our clothing. We all wear the same things. Our styles have completely overlapped. Civilians and soldiers alike, now wear performance clothes. Waterproof shells, sweat-wicking layers, often manufactured by the same companies. We all wear outdoor wear, whether or not we're outdoors.
我们被挑拨离间。然而，奇怪的是，美国士兵和美国平民在我们的服装中从未像现在这样紧密相连。我们都穿同样的东西。我们的风格已经完全重叠。平民和士兵一样，现在都穿功能性服装。防水外壳、排汗层，通常由同一家公司制造。无论我们是否在户外，我们都穿户外服装。
And we helped each other get to this place. This season of Articles of Interest is called Gear. It does not take a fashion journalist to tell you that everybody is wearing outdoor clothes more. Look around you. For years now, leggings have been pants, and runners have been dashing by you in increasingly more cyborgian rainproof shells. Bankers and businessmen have traded blazers for Patagonia vests, and punks have swapped leather for camouflage,
我们互相帮助才走到这一步。这一季的Articles of Interest名为“装备”。不需要时尚记者告诉你，每个人都在更多地穿户外服装。看看你周围。多年来，紧身裤一直是裤子，跑步者穿着越来越像赛博格的防雨外壳从你身边冲过。银行家和商人们已经用Patagonia背心取代了西装外套，朋克们已经用迷彩服取代了皮革，
and even I, who vowed I would never wear sweatpants ever, have been dressing like sporty spice. Why are we all wearing outdoor performance gear? Like, why are we wearing Arcterics to, like, go to the grocery store and buy eggs? I think there are two different reasons. And one that will be a little more palatable for all the listeners to hear is that it works well, right? It's effective in, like, a day like today, it's raining outside,
甚至连发誓永远不穿运动裤的我，也一直打扮得像运动辣妹。为什么我们都穿户外功能装备？比如，为什么我们穿着始祖鸟去杂货店买鸡蛋？我认为有两个不同的原因。其中一个对所有听众来说可能更容易接受，那就是它效果很好，对吧？它很有效，比如像今天这样的一天，外面在下雨，
and it's nice to be able to stay warm and dry. even if you're just going down the block. This is Rachel S. Gross. I'm a history professor at the University of Colorado, Denver. And she is the author of Shopping All the Way to the Woods, how the outdoor industry sold nature to America. The other answer is a much kind of deeper one, and it's a historical question.
即使你只是去街区那边，能保持温暖和干燥也很好。这是Rachel S. Gross。我是科罗拉多大学丹佛分校的历史学教授。她是《一路购物到森林：户外行业如何向美国兜售自然》的作者。另一个答案是一个更深层次的，这是一个历史问题。
Hell yeah, here we go. It's about what meanings do people attach to the kinds of clothing that they wear, to the brands that they're wearing on their chests. And it is steeped in American lore about recovering the rugged masculinity of the American frontier. By the way, I know America is a landmass much larger than the United States. I also get annoyed when people in the United States think they are the only Americans, but please have pity on me. The name of my country is so long, and no one says U.Sians or United Stadians. And so please know that for my purposes, when I say America, I do mean the United States
太棒了，我们开始吧。这是关于人们赋予他们所穿服装、他们胸前佩戴的品牌什么样的意义。它沉浸在美国关于恢复美国边境粗犷男子气概的传说中。顺便说一句，我知道美洲是一个比美国大得多的陆地。当美国人认为他们是唯一的美国人时，我也感到恼火，但请怜悯我。我的国家名字太长了，没有人说“U.Sians”或“United Stadians”。所以请知道，为了我的目的，当我提到美国时，我确实是指美利坚合众国，
of America, okay? And so, the United States of America, for the purposes of this podcast, America is about to turn 250 years old, just narrowly outliving some ruff-eye rockfish and bowhead whales. And yet, for fully the last half of our relatively young existence, we have been already overwhelmed with a national sense of nostalgia. The notion that somehow Americans of the past, the pioneers, were tougher, more virile than their urban, effeminate counterparts. In the hearts of American men, for at least 125 years,
好吧？所以，美利坚合众国，为了这个播客的目的，美国即将满250岁，仅仅比一些粗眼岩鱼和弓头鲸长寿一点点。然而，在我们相对年轻的存在的最后一半时间里，我们已经被一种民族怀旧感所淹没。这种观念认为，过去的美国人，那些先驱者，比他们城市里柔弱的同龄人更坚强、更有活力。在美国男人的心中，至少125年来，
there's been a gap unfilable in soft, cushy, effete modernity. It is only by encountering some kind of tough physical challenge that they can recover some sense of that lost masculinity. Donald Trump Jr. goes on expensive hunting trips to shoot rare sheep and endangered duck. Mark Zuckerberg bohunts wild boar. Outdoor recreation, going camping, hunting or fishing. When it is pursued as a recreational activity in the 19th century,
在柔软、舒适、虚弱的现代性中一直存在着无法填补的空白。只有通过遇到某种艰难的身体挑战，他们才能恢复那种失去的男子气概。小唐纳德·特朗普去昂贵的狩猎旅行射杀稀有绵羊和濒危鸭子。马克·扎克伯格用弓箭狩猎野猪。户外娱乐，去露营、狩猎或钓鱼。当它在19世纪作为一种娱乐活动被追求时，
it is often men looking to perform that form of manhood. And so what do men wear when they are performing manhood? There was always an insistence that, no, it wasn't a costume, it wasn't style. No, men don't care about that kind of stuff. It was about pure practicality. And so being anti-fashion was one of the most important touchstones of outdoor style from the 19th century onward. But yeah, fashion is totally a part of going.
它通常是男人试图表演那种男子气概。那么当男人表演男子气概时穿什么呢？一直有一种坚持，不，那不是服装，那不是风格。不，男人不在乎那种东西。这是关于纯粹的实用性。所以反时尚是19世纪以来户外风格最重要的基石之一。但是，是的，时尚完全是去户外的一部分。
outside. It always has been. Even just the simple idea that you change your clothes to go do a specific activity. I think people have long put on separate costumes to go hiker hunt. And this isn't a particularly American phenomenon. In England, the elite classes also had specialized outfit to do similar activities outside of the city at their lodges. But American outdoorsman had a sort of American outdoorsman costume. In the United States, though, it wasn't a It wasn't English hunting suits that were popular in the 19th century, but rather an odd combination of white people looking at American Indian style and what they thought pioneers would have worn in the U.S. past. American outdoorsmen were supposed to dress like Johnny Appleseed and Davy Crockett and Daniel Boone. And what did those guys wear?
它一直都是。即使只是你换衣服去进行特定活动的简单想法。我认为人们长期以来一直穿上单独的服装去徒步或狩猎。这并不是一个特别的美国现象。在英国，精英阶层也有专门的服装在城市之外的旅馆里进行类似的活动。但美国户外运动者有一种美国户外运动者的服装。然而，在美国，19世纪流行的不是英国狩猎服，而是一种奇怪的组合，白人看着美国印第安人的风格和他们认为先驱者在美国过去会穿的衣服。美国户外运动者应该打扮得像Johnny Appleseed、Davy Crockett和Daniel Boone。那些家伙穿什么？
Fringy, rugged, leather, buckskin suits. And so that means we get a lot of white men. wearing buckskin suits because they think it's a combination of the expert lore of both Native American guides and also the Daniel Boone's that they want to imitate as well. And where did many of these white men get this idea from? Guidebooks. A writer named William H.H. Murray, or Adirondack Murray, arguably kick-started the outdoor recreation industry in 1869 when he published a guidebook called Adventures in the Wilderness or Camp Life in the Adirondacks. This was a guidebook that instructed city dwellers what to do, where to stay, and how to dress the part of the outdoorsman. The ethos of the 19th century outdoors was woodcraft, crafting what you need from nature's storehouse in order to survive. This inspired a raft of new guidebooks, some written by white men hiding behind indigenous pen names, who endorsed the idea of crafting over buying and framed the nature vacation as anti-materialistic.
流苏、粗犷、皮革、鹿皮套装。这意味着我们有很多白人穿着鹿皮套装，因为他们认为这是结合了美洲原住民向导的专家知识和他们想要模仿的Daniel Boone的传说。许多白人从哪里得到这个想法的？指南书。一位名叫William H.H. Murray（或Adirondack Murray）的作家在1869年出版了一本名为《荒野中的冒险或阿迪朗达克山的露营生活》的指南书，可以说开启了户外娱乐行业。这是一本指导城市居民做什么、住在哪里以及如何打扮成户外运动者的指南书。19世纪户外的精神是木工，从自然仓库中制作你需要的东西以生存。这激发了一批新的指南书，有些是由躲在土著笔名后的白人写的，他们支持制作而不是购买的想法，并将自然度假定义为反物质主义。
True American outdoorsmen, these books said, needed nothing from the Nambi-Pambi world of commerce. Many guidebooks often told its readers don't buy anything. If you do, you're essentially showing yourself to be a beginner who doesn't know anything really about what the nature experience is supposed to be. And so a lot of readers took that to heart and thought, I have to craft my own buckskin suit. And that included not just shooting the deer, the buck,
这些书说，真正的美国户外运动者不需要商业世界的任何东西。许多指南书经常告诉读者不要买任何东西。如果你买了，你基本上是在表明自己是一个什么都不懂的初学者，不知道自然体验应该是什么样的。所以很多读者把这放在心上，想，我必须制作我自己的鹿皮套装。这不仅包括射杀鹿，
but also learning how to brain tan the hide in order to get it soft and pliable and sewing the suit together themselves. But did everyone do this? Very few people did, including the guidebook authors themselves. No. The most avid wearers of buckskin suits functionally went shopping. They often turned to Native American women who were the recognized experts at sewing buckskin suits. So they would just buy them?
还包括学习如何用脑鞣制兽皮以使其柔软柔韧，并自己缝制套装。但每个人都这样做吗？很少有人这样做，包括指南书作者本人。不。鹿皮套装最狂热的穿着者实际上是去购物。他们经常求助于被公认为缝制鹿皮套装专家的美洲原住民女性。所以他们只是买它们？
They would just buy them. Shopping is a cornerstone of the American relationship with the outdoors. To this day, when you think about it, it is sort of perversely fascinating that any trip into the outdoors starts with getting kidded up. You have to go shopping. You need all this stuff to do what ought to be the most natural thing, going to sleep outside. And already, in the 1860s, America was already imagining how much more self-sufficient, how much more rugged, men used to be. But come on, since it was a cornerstone of the founding of the United States to completely ignore, if not annihilate any form of indigenous knowledge about how to actually live in this land
他们只是买它们。购物是美国与户外关系的一个基石。直到今天，当你想到它时，任何户外旅行都始于装备齐全，这在某种程度上是反常的迷人。你必须去购物。你需要所有这些东西来做本应该是最自然的事情，在户外睡觉。早在1860年代，美国就已经在想象男人过去是多么自给自足，多么粗犷。但是，拜托，因为完全忽视，如果不是消灭任何关于如何真正生活在这片土地上的土著知识，是美国建国的基石，
and adapt to this climate, white settlers didn't know how to actually dress for this country. And so they bought stuff. They always have. It's foundational. If you go back all the way to the 1700s, to the earliest days, before the official founding of this nation, it was always a thing to shop for gear. With the help of the Native Americans,
并且适应这种气候，白人定居者不知道如何真正为这个国家穿衣。所以他们买了东西。他们一直都是这样。这是基础。如果你一直追溯到1700年代，在官方建国之前的最早日子里，购买装备一直是一件事。在美洲原住民的帮助下，
making buckskins because buckskins were being turned into buckskin breeches, and they were a equivalent of blue jeans of the 18th century is how they're often described. Early English colonizers took a liking to the Indian-style buckskin breaches, not only because they were hard-wearing and practical, it was also a style thing. The buckskin breaches had this rugged, indigenous look. to them. Americans were always dressing up to look more rugged than they were. This was the 1700s version of wearing Arcterics to go to the grocery store. The buckskin breaches became so
制作鹿皮，因为鹿皮被做成鹿皮马裤，它们通常被描述为18世纪的蓝色牛仔裤。早期的英国殖民者喜欢印第安风格的鹿皮马裤，不仅因为它们耐穿实用，而且也是一种风格。鹿皮马裤有一种粗犷的土著外观。美国人总是打扮得看起来比他们实际更粗犷。这是1700年代穿着始祖鸟去杂货店的版本。鹿皮马裤变得如此
popular in the colonies that the trend spread back to England. It got to the point where in the 1750s, Savannah, Georgia was processing 150,000 pounds of buckskin a year. We nearly, like, hunted deer to extinction in, like, Georgia and the Carolinas. This is Joshua a Kerner, who I'm just going to call Kerner. A lot of people do say this is what Kerner says when they reference me in other places. Kerner is actually an attorney in Richmond, Virginia. His day job
在殖民地流行，以至于这种趋势传回了英国。到了1750年代，萨凡纳、佐治亚州每年加工15万磅鹿皮。我们几乎在佐治亚州和卡罗来纳州把鹿猎杀到灭绝。这是Joshua A. Kerner，我简称为Kerner。当人们在其他地方引用我时，很多人确实会说这是Kerner说的。Kerner实际上是弗吉尼亚州里士满的一名律师。他的日常工作
has nothing to do with this, but he moonlights as a war reenactor and a deep archival research obsessive. Kerner is, in fact, so well-versed in the history of military uniforms and uniform procurement that I've seen actual military historians and archivists defer
与此无关，但他兼职做战争重演者和深度档案研究狂。事实上，Kerner对军服和制服采购的历史非常精通，以至于我见过真正的军事历史学家和档案管理员向他请教。
to him. I would feel very okay with being called a citizen researcher if you're on to be generous. If you want to call me a World War II nutso, that is also fine. As an aside, Kerner holds the record for the longest interview I have ever done in my career, clocking in at 14 hours, 10 minutes, and 45 seconds. I have an interest in it over the entire spance of the U.S. Army's existence. And so, before the United States Army even existed, there was this trend for buckskin breaches. And so a lot of deer had to be shot to meet this demand.
如果你慷慨的话，我会觉得被称为公民研究员非常可以。如果你想叫我二战狂人，那也可以。顺便说一句，Kerner保持着我职业生涯中最长采访的记录，长达14小时10分45秒。我对美国陆军存在的整个跨度都很感兴趣。所以，在美国陆军存在之前，就有这种鹿皮马裤的趋势。因此，为了满足这种需求，必须射杀很多鹿。
And so there was a garment that the hunters around the Virginia colony developed to hunt all these deer for this global fashion trend. And the garment that these Virginia hunters wore was called, simply enough, the hunting shirt. The hunting shirt, which is something that comes from this Shenandoah back country. And it's decorated with fringe, so it still has this faux indigenous look to it. but it's way cheaper than buckskin. It's made out of linen.
所以弗吉尼亚殖民地周围的猎人开发了一种服装来猎杀所有这些鹿，以满足这种全球时尚趋势。这些弗吉尼亚猎人穿的服装很简单，叫狩猎衫。狩猎衫，来自谢南多厄腹地。它装饰着流苏，所以它仍然有一种伪土著的外观，但它比鹿皮便宜得多。它是用亚麻布做的。
A hunting shirt is a big, roomy smock. Super simple garment that's easy to make. You just have to finish off some seas, you pull some fringe, and you have an easy uniform. So militias in Virginia start wearing these hunting shirts. It turns out to be a simple way to get uniformity, because this shirt is very distinctive, and you can just slide it on over anything.
狩猎衫是一件宽大、宽松的罩衫。超级简单的服装，很容易制作。你只需要完成一些缝合，拉出一些流苏，你就有一个简单的制服。所以弗吉尼亚的民兵开始穿这些狩猎衫。事实证明，这是一种获得统一性的简单方法，因为这件衬衫非常独特，你可以把它套在任何东西外面。
It does mean because the way they're cut means you just wear it over whatever else you have. have. And then, when these Virginian militias hear that their brothers in the north need help fighting the British, they march up to Massachusetts wearing their hunting shirts, many now with the words liberty or death embroidered on the chest. Once the Virginians got to New England, General George Washington himself quickly requested, quote, a number of hunting shirts, not less than 10,000, because he knew that a uniform of some kind would, quote, have a happier tendency to unite the men.
这意味着因为它们的剪裁方式，你只是把它穿在任何你有的东西外面。然后，当这些弗吉尼亚民兵听说他们在北方的兄弟需要帮助对抗英国人时，他们穿着狩猎衫向马萨诸塞进军，许多人现在胸前绣着“自由或死亡”的字样。一旦弗吉尼亚人到达新英格兰，乔治·华盛顿将军本人很快就要求，引用，“不少于10,000件狩猎衫”，因为他知道某种制服会，引用，“有一种更快乐的倾向来团结士兵”。
The hunting shirt gets introduced into the wider army during the siege of Boston in 1775, thanks to the arrival of Washington and the Corps of Riflemen. So there was this idea that maybe American fighters would all wear hunting shirts. This would be a sort of non-uniform uniform. This might be perfect,
狩猎衫在1775年波士顿围城战期间被引入更广泛的军队，多亏了华盛顿和步枪兵团的到来。所以当时有一种想法，也许美国战士都会穿狩猎衫。这将是一种非制服的制服。这可能是完美的，
because maybe the United States wouldn't need an official proper uniform, because this nation wouldn't have an official proper army. A lot of the founding fathers, especially Thomas Jefferson, looked back to early democracies of antiquity, and they were like, look, a standing army usually means trouble. Looking back at the classical ideas and the idea that the reason Rome fell and the Roman Republic fell was the standing army.
因为也许美国不需要正式的正式制服，因为这个国家不会有正式的正式军队。许多开国元勋，特别是托马斯·杰斐逊，回顾古代的早期民主国家，他们说，看，常备军通常意味着麻烦。回顾古典思想，罗马灭亡和罗马共和国灭亡的原因是常备军。
Military coups are known to happen. But also standing armies are expensive. The Republic is young, and we don't have any money yet. So there isn't a lot of money for, Congress to play with, to give an army. And paying people to do military service or requiring service in America would be antithetical to the whole project. I mean, demanding service was what kings used to do.
军事政变是众所周知的。而且常备军很昂贵。共和国很年轻，我们还没有钱。所以国会没有多少钱可以玩，给军队。而在美国支付人们服兵役或要求服役将与整个项目背道而驰。我的意思是，要求服役是国王过去做的事情。
But anyway, we don't need an army. We are, in fact, better than that. Perhaps Washington and Jefferson thought, our citizens, white male ones, of course, will voluntarily take up arms for the cause of democracy. The founding fathers somewhat fetishized the idea of the citizen soldier as being someone who's going to be superior to a career soldier who fights for money because they're fighting out of patriotism. This is author and veteran Phil Kly who has explored the history of service a fair amount. And they thought that mercenaries are going to be terrible soldiers, but people who are fighting out of patriotism will fight more valiantly and thus better. So this was the whole idea behind our militias.
但无论如何，我们不需要军队。事实上，我们比那更好。也许华盛顿和杰斐逊认为，我们的公民，当然是白人男性，会自愿为民主事业拿起武器。开国元勋们在某种程度上迷恋公民士兵的想法，认为他们会比为钱而战的职业士兵更优越，因为他们是出于爱国主义而战。这是作家兼退伍军人Phil Kly，他深入探讨了服役的历史。他们认为雇佣兵会是糟糕的士兵，但出于爱国主义而战的人会更英勇，因此更好。这就是我们民兵背后的整个想法。
These were just supposed to be groups of folks who would take up arms voluntarily, passionately, at the drop of a hat who didn't need fancy uniforms or anything. They would just toss on their linen hunting shirts and go off and fight for their friends and countrymen. Just get on your hunting shirt. Let's go. And then at the Battle of Brooklyn... One of the first major battles of the Revolution. The Hessian mercenaries were professionals at war, and the Americans weren't. The British had hired German mercenary soldiers, the Hessians, who were ruthless killers for hire. At the Battle of Brooklyn, Hessian mercenaries whooped the citizen soldiers pretty badly.
这些本应只是一群会自愿、热情地拿起武器的人，他们不需要昂贵的制服或任何东西。他们只会穿上他们的亚麻狩猎衫，去为他们的朋友和同胞而战。只要穿上你的狩猎衫。我们走吧。然后在布鲁克林战役中……革命的主要战役之一。黑森雇佣兵是战争专家，而美国人不是。英国人雇佣了德国雇佣兵，黑森人，他们是无情的杀手。在布鲁克林战役中，黑森雇佣兵把公民士兵打得很惨。
There's this big reconsideration. Maybe we couldn't just rely on militias. Maybe we did need to have an actual regular professional standing army dressed in something a little bit better than linen smocks. Maybe they should be actual uniforms made of actual sturdy wool. They opted to put soldiers in a British-style uniform. What else did they know? Our colonial button-down regimental coats looked basically identical to the red coats, but ours were blue.
有一个大的重新考虑。也许我们不能只依赖民兵。也许我们确实需要有一支真正的正规职业常备军，穿着比亚麻罩衫好一点的东西。也许他们应该是用真正的结实羊毛制成的实际制服。他们选择让士兵穿英式制服。他们还知道什么？我们的殖民地扣领团服外套看起来基本上和红衫军一模一样，但我们的是蓝色的。
We think of Army green now, but it used to be Army blue was the color of the military. Kerner again. This is like Army Blue that goes back to the American Revolution. Indigo was already growing on early plantations in the United States, so the color blue was easily accessible. On smoky battlefields, where bayonet fighting and shooting happened at close range, team colors had to be clear. Because friendly fire is surprisingly common and is bad.
我们现在想到陆军绿，但过去陆军蓝是军队的颜色。Kerner再次提到。这就像可以追溯到美国革命的陆军蓝。靛蓝已经在美国的早期种植园里生长，所以蓝色很容易获得。在烟雾缭绕的战场上，刺刀格斗和射击发生在近距离，团队颜色必须清晰。因为友军误伤非常普遍且糟糕。
During the Revolutionary War, U.S. military clothes had a very British influence. And then, when the United States of America won its independence, they started searching for their own identity through their military clothes. In the 19th century, what would often happen is an officer would go on an exchange trip to somewhere in Europe. And he would see some uniform items. And like, I kind of like that. I mean, they wanted the color. to stay blue, but the style was called into question.
在革命战争期间，美国军装有非常浓厚的英国影响。然后，当美利坚合众国赢得独立时，他们开始通过军装寻找自己的身份。在19世纪，经常发生的情况是一名军官去欧洲某个地方进行交流旅行。他会看到一些制服物品。就像，我有点喜欢那个。我的意思是，他们希望颜色保持蓝色，但风格受到了质疑。
A lot of it is taking inspiration from whoever is seen as the dominant military power at the time. So we switched to French-style uniforms in the 1840s. We wear these jaunty little caps, and we look like little nutcracker soldiers. And we are still in that French influence extending into the Civil War, where the Union Army is, for the first time, wearing clothes produced on a mass scale. Machine stoning isn't really introduced into the U.S. Army system until the Civil War itself to expedite manufacture. Throughout the course of the Civil War, you have 2 million northern soldiers, so a lot of uniforms needed to be produced. There is a pattern and drafting division. This is the notorious origins of the sizes, small, medium, and large.
很多是从当时被视为主要军事力量的人那里汲取灵感。所以我们在1840年代换成了法式制服。我们戴着这些俏皮的小帽子，看起来像小胡桃夹子士兵。我们仍然处于那种延伸到内战的法国影响中，联邦军队第一次穿着大规模生产的衣服。机器缝纫直到内战本身才真正引入美国陆军系统，以加快制造速度。在内战过程中，你有200万北方士兵，所以需要生产大量的制服。有一个图案和绘图部门。这就是小、中、大尺寸的臭名昭著的起源。
The government contracted with manufacturers like Brooks Brothers to get uniforms made, still in blue. But contracting uniforms out ended up being a mess. I'm not trying to throw Brooks Brothers under the bus here specifically, but by and large, the government ended up not being able to trust a lot of these private companies. Because they want the biggest profit margin, they would get substandard materials, and that wasn't really noticeable until you were. These substandard materials were called shoddy. This is why, to this day, we still call busted things shoddy. Then you had what was called shoddy then, which would easily fall apart. And you do not want your pants to rip on the battlefield. it's not a place for a button to come off
政府与Brooks Brothers等制造商签约制作制服，仍然是蓝色的。但外包制服最终成了一团糟。我并不是特别想把Brooks Brothers推到风口浪尖，但总的来说，政府最终无法信任许多这些私营公司。因为他们想要最大的利润率，他们会得到不合格的材料，直到你穿上它才真正注意到。这些不合格的材料被称为“劣质品”（shoddy）。这就是为什么直到今天，我们仍然称破烂的东西为“shoddy”。当时所谓的劣质品很容易散架。你绝对不希望你的裤子在战场上撕裂。这不是纽扣掉落的地方
or a knit to come undone or a thread to pull. And there's a lot of these lessons that were learned during the American Civil War and making sure that the government is getting what they're paying for and that the soldiers on the receiving in are getting the best uniforms that the government can buy.
或者针织品散开或线拉出的地方。在内战期间学到了很多教训，确保政府得到他们支付的东西，并且接收端的士兵得到政府能买到的最好的制服。
This is a trial and error process throughout the Civil War. You finally start having inspectors who would approve military-grade garments with a literal stamp of approval. Right here. Inspection stamp. Yep.
这是整个内战期间的试错过程。你终于开始有检查员，他们会用字面上的批准印章批准军用级服装。就在这里。检查印章。是的。
U.S. Inspector. And these inspectors came from a branch of the U.S. military, known as the quartermaster department, which would later become the quartermaster corps. This is the division of the military responsible for feeding, sheltering, transporting, and clothing the troops. This is not a heavy flannel. But it's also unstructured. It also is a soft-structured. Completely unstructured.
美国检查员。这些检查员来自美国军方的一个分支，即军需部，后来成为军需兵团。这是军方负责喂养、安置、运输和装备部队的部门。这不是厚法兰绒。但它也是非结构化的。它也是一种软结构。完全非结构化。
Kerner and I were at the Quartermaster Corps Museum in Fort Lee in Virginia, So we were able to look at some of the samples from American Uniform history. This is a Civil War coat. This Civil War coat that Kerner and I were looking at was a blue flannel coat with gold-tone brass buttons. It almost looked like a blue blazer you'd get at Brooks Brothers. It was really nice. Wow.
Kerner和我当时在弗吉尼亚州李堡的军需兵团博物馆，所以我们能够查看美国制服历史的一些样本。这是一件内战外套。Kerner和我正在看的这件内战外套是一件蓝色法兰绒外套，带有金色的黄铜纽扣。它看起来几乎像你在Brooks Brothers买的蓝色西装外套。它真的很不错。哇。
Here you go. And this was made from dyed indigo flannel. And sure enough, there was the quartermaster stamp of approval. Oh, this was a nice jacket. So while all countries have quartermaster, the Americans take it to a different level of an art form. It was this combination of quality controls that were developed during the Civil War and the ongoing land grab from the ongoing bloody Indian wars across the American West,
给你。这是用染色靛蓝法兰绒制成的。果然，上面有军需部的批准印章。哦，这是一件不错的夹克。所以虽然所有国家都有军需官，但美国人把它提升到了艺术形式的另一个层面。这是内战期间开发的质量控制与美国西部持续血腥印第安战争中持续的土地掠夺的结合，
which raged on throughout the century. Because of our long history, having to supply an army over a vast nation. I mean, this was the process that I was taught in school was just westward expansion. And yet it really was an ongoing series of wars. Between 1776 and the early 1900s, there were about 2,500 battles between North American tribes and the United States Army. That's a pretty rough statistic, though. It varies a lot depending on how you define a battle.
这在整个世纪里都在肆虐。因为我们漫长的历史，必须在一个广阔的国家供应军队。我的意思是，我在学校里学到的这个过程只是向西扩张。然而，这确实是一系列持续的战争。在1776年到1900年代初之间，北美部落和美国陆军之间发生了大约2500场战斗。这是一个相当粗略的统计数据。它根据你如何定义战斗而有很大不同。
Like, is it a battle if the U.S. Army is just opening fire on a bunch of people? Hard to say. But especially after the Civil War, the indigenous population was all the United States military, had to focus on. So they did. Outside of the Civil War, largely the American Army is a constabulary force that is doled out to cross the American West. In the 1800s, the United States Quartermaster Corps was getting very good at manufacturing a high volume of good quality clothes and then delivering them to far-flung forts. And under those circumstances where you had to
比如，如果美国陆军只是向一群人开火，那算战斗吗？很难说。但特别是在内战之后，土著人口是美国军方必须关注的全部。所以他们这样做了。在内战之外，美国陆军在很大程度上是一支被分配到美国西部的警察部队。在1800年代，美国军需兵团在制造大量高质量服装并将其运送到遥远的堡垒方面变得非常擅长。在那种情况下，你必须
supply these far-off garrisons by covered wagon pulled by a horse, it forced to creation and mindset of logistical competence at all levels. And after the Civil War, the first mass-produced factory-scale war, this is the first war with excess stuff left over. Which kind of gives rise to the surplus industry. It's not widespread yet. There aren't a lot of surplus stores, but the few that do exist are super popular. Take, for example, a Scottish merchant in New York named Francis Bannerman.
用马拉的篷车为这些偏远的驻军提供补给，迫使各级人员在后勤能力上进行创新并形成相应的思维模式。内战之后，这是第一次大规模的工厂化战争，也是第一次有大量剩余物资的战争。这在某种程度上催生了剩余物资产业。虽然当时还不普遍，剩余物资商店也不多，但仅有的几家却非常受欢迎。以纽约的一位苏格兰商人弗朗西斯·班纳曼为例。
Bannerman gets to start selling off all the surplus, dating me. back to the Civil War. Eventually, he acquires so much stuff that he buys a private island to store it all. Bannerman's castle is a little bit up the Hudson River, and to give you an idea of how much surplus they had, they were selling these old Civil War Rifles for essentially scrap metal. And so after the Civil War, there's this very interesting period. It felt to a lot of Americans like peacetime. I mean, in the same way that I feel like I live in peacetime, even though I don't. I just live in a bubble. After the Civil War, it was very easy for a lot of Americans to just ignore the Indian Wars. They're still raging on and claiming thousands of lives. So just to make this perfectly
班纳曼开始兜售所有追溯到内战时期的剩余物资。最终，他积攒了太多的东西，以至于买下了一个私人岛屿来存放它们。班纳曼城堡位于哈德逊河上游，为了让你了解他们有多少剩余物资，他们当时把这些旧的内战步枪基本上当作废金属来卖。所以内战后，出现了一个非常有趣的时期。对许多美国人来说，这感觉像是和平时期。我的意思是，就像我觉得自己生活在和平时期一样，尽管事实并非如此。我只是生活在一个泡沫中。内战后，许多美国人很容易就忽视了印第安战争。它们仍在激烈进行，夺去了成千上万人的生命。所以，为了把这一点说得非常
clear, this was not a period of peace. Arguably, America has never had a period of peace, but to many Americans, this time did feel like a period of peace after the Civil War. Just know that that's not true. And it started to look like a period of peace. Kerner has this pet theory that military dress gets more practical and simple in wartime and increasingly ornate and dressy in what feels like peacetime. During war, everything has to get simplified and ready for the trenches, and then when you get into peace again, the uniform is more concerned with how it looks on the parade ground. This period after the Civil War, even though it's not actually peace, this is probably
清楚，这并不是一个和平时期。可以说，美国从未有过和平时期，但对许多美国人来说，这段时间在内战后确实感觉像是和平时期。要知道，事实并非如此。而且它开始看起来像是一个和平时期。克纳有一个个人理论，即军装在战时变得更加实用和简洁，而在感觉像是和平时期时则变得越来越华丽和讲究。在战争期间，一切都必须简化并为战壕做好准备，而当你再次进入和平时期，制服就更关注在阅兵场上的样子了。内战后的这段时期，虽然实际上并非和平，但这可能是我
my favorite chapter of the American military uniform, it's bonkers. So, yeah, this is enlisted men, 1872, 1871. Look at this super fancy plume on this Prussian-inspired helmet, all the gold hassles and hide. Totally. The American Army is now copying the Prussians who have beat the French in the Franco-Prussian War. The U.S. is still wearing their signature Army blue, but the style is now so fancy pants.
最喜欢的美国军装篇章，简直太疯狂了。所以，是的，这是1872年、1871年的士兵制服。看看这顶普鲁士风格头盔上超级华丽的羽饰，还有所有的金色流苏和皮毛。完全是这样。美国陆军现在正在模仿在普法战争中击败法国人的普鲁士人。美国人仍然穿着他们标志性的陆军蓝，但款式现在变得非常花哨。
We take a lot more Prussian influences and adopt a pickle helmet, actually, for a while, for both the Marine Corps and the Army. It's that helmet that Otto von Bismarck would become. I'm famous for. It looks like it's got this like butt-plug spike sticking out of the top. You would never know that these are Americans. And as military uniforms got fancier and fancier and more and more absurd, so did the idea of war in general.
我们吸收了更多普鲁士的影响，甚至有一段时间为海军陆战队和陆军采用了尖顶头盔。那就是奥托·冯·俾斯麦出名的那种头盔。它看起来顶部插着一个像塞子一样的尖刺。你永远不会想到这是美国人。随着军装变得越来越华丽、越来越荒谬，战争的概念也随之变得荒谬。
East Coast Americans removed from the ongoing Indian wars in the West were unaccustomed to going this long without what they would consider an official war. Again, these years after the Civil War were not peaceful. there's a lot of violence happening in the American West, but in the eyes of the American government, and many of its people, this feels like a period of peace. And by this logic, an assertive group of activists and legislators were like, maybe this is a part of the ongoing American experiment.
远离西部持续不断的印第安战争的东海岸美国人，不习惯这么长时间没有他们所认为的“正式战争”。再说一次，内战后的这些年并不和平。美国西部发生了大量的暴力事件，但在美国政府及其许多民众眼中，这感觉像是一个和平时期。按照这个逻辑，一群自信的活动家和立法者认为，也许这是正在进行的美国实验的一部分。
We got rid of kings, we abolished slavery, and now maybe war is just another, antiquated system that we could get rid of. How American is that, right? We have this, like, beautiful, idealistic, hypocritical goal that we have yet to achieve. But we seriously tried to do it. There was a movement to make pacifism an American value. After the break. We're back with Avery Truffleman and more articles of interest. Although Teddy Roosevelt liked to pass himself off as the ultimate manly hunter rugged outdoorsman, he was a New York City kid.
我们摆脱了国王，废除了奴隶制，现在也许战争只是另一个我们可以摆脱的过时制度。这多有美国特色，对吧？我们有这样一个美丽、理想化但又虚伪的目标，我们尚未实现。但我们确实认真尝试过。当时有一场运动旨在使和平主义成为一种美国价值观。休息之后，我们将带回艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和更多感兴趣的文章。尽管西奥多·罗斯福喜欢把自己伪装成终极的男子汉、猎人和粗犷的户外运动者，但他其实是个纽约市长大的孩子。
This is so funny to me that I could just hop on the subway and go to the Theodore Roosevelt birthplace. It's right here. It's in Manhattan. In the 1800s, the Roosevelt's were one of the richest families in New York City. There it is. He's 20th Street. Theodore Roosevelt Way.
这对我来说太有趣了，我可以跳上地铁去西奥多·罗斯福的出生地。它就在这里，在曼哈顿。在19世纪，罗斯福家族是纽约市最富有的家庭之一。就在那儿，第20街，西奥多·罗斯福路。
He must have passed this a million times. The stately building that is landmarked as the birthplace of Theodore Roosevelt isn't actually the building that Teddy was born in. That was once right down the street. This is Teddy's uncle's house. But the floor plan is similar, and all the furniture is authentic. All four of the Roosevelt children
他一定经过这里一百万次了。作为西奥多·罗斯福出生地而被列为地标的宏伟建筑，实际上并不是泰迪出生的那栋楼。那栋楼曾经就在街下。这是泰迪叔叔的房子。但平面图很相似，所有的家具都是真品。罗斯福家的四个孩子
were not born in this room. They were born in this bed, however. The Roosevelt birthplace is a national park, and they give free tours a couple times a day. My main takeaway from my tour was that Teddy Roosevelt loved his dad. President Roosevelt says in his autobiography that his father was the greatest man he ever knew.
并不是出生在这个房间里。不过，他们确实出生在这张床上。罗斯福出生地是一个国家公园，他们每天提供几次免费参观。我参观后的主要收获是，泰迪·罗斯福非常爱他的父亲。罗斯福总统在自传中说，他的父亲是他所认识的最伟大的人。
Theodore Roosevelt Sr. does sound pretty great, even though my tour guide also sounds pretty biased himself. Theodore Roosevelt Sr. was outstanding in the fact that he was atypical of a father and a husband. Before he went to work, his first obligation was to spend time and show attention and affection to his four children. I suppose the bare minimum of showing attention to your family was pretty remarkable for his time. Although, to be fair, it does sound like Theodore Roosevelt Sr. was very nurturing to his four children. including his poor, sickly son, Teddy. Our future president, he's born with severe, severe asthma. And that asthma, it was feared that it would overtake him at any point in time.
西奥多·罗斯福老先生听起来确实很棒，尽管我的导游听起来也很有偏见。西奥多·罗斯福老先生的杰出之处在于他作为父亲和丈夫的非典型性。在他去工作之前，他的首要义务是花时间向他的四个孩子展示关注和爱。我想，在那个时代，给予家人最起码的关注已经相当了不起了。虽然平心而论，西奥多·罗斯福老先生对他的四个孩子确实非常悉心照料，包括他那个可怜、体弱多病的儿子泰迪。我们未来的总统，他出生时就患有严重的哮喘。人们担心这种哮喘随时会夺走他的生命。
And Thee is looking at his four children and says, I am so, so proud of your brilliance. And I'm so disappointed that you are pathetic as far as your physical capabilities. I don't think this is verbatim. I just think this is a tour guide being a little mean. Do something about that. Essentially, the Roosevelt children say, Papa has said, we have to build ourselves up.
而老罗斯福看着他的四个孩子说，我为你们的才华感到无比自豪。但我对你们在身体能力上的软弱感到非常失望。我不认为这是原话。我只是觉得这是导游有点刻薄。做点什么吧。本质上，罗斯福的孩子们说，爸爸说了，我们必须锻炼自己。
We must lead the strenuous life life. This becomes a rallying cry for young Roosevelt. He must live the strenuous life. He has to deal with his own asthma. Because at this point in history, even medical experts are not very good at treating asthma. And the treatment protocols say, give the baby a cigar to smoke.
我们必须过“艰苦的生活”。这成了年轻罗斯福的战斗口号。他必须过艰苦的生活。他必须应对自己的哮喘。因为在那个历史时期，即使是医学专家也不太擅长治疗哮喘。而治疗方案竟然是，给婴儿一支雪茄抽。
No, they do not. I'm not making that up. But the future 26th president of the United States did find a treatment that worked for him. Hot black coffee, in combination with physical exercise. Allegedly, from his early childhood, Teddy Roosevelt is just pounding hot black coffee. So much so that when he's president of the United States, he's clocking a minimum of a gallon of hot coffee a day. Cheers. Coffee, in conjunction with physical exercise, transformed him.
不，他们没有。我不是编的。但这位美国第26任总统确实找到了一种对他有效的治疗方法。热黑咖啡，结合体育锻炼。据称，从童年早期开始，泰迪·罗斯福就在狂喝热黑咖啡。以至于当他担任美国总统时，他每天至少要喝一加仑热咖啡。干杯。咖啡结合体育锻炼改变了他。
And Roosevelt, as a child, was his sickly child. He had a high, squeaky voice, people ridiculed him. Kristen Hogan is a professor of history at the University of Illinois. I think that helps explain why he went off to the Dakotas to become a ranch man, right? On the cover of his 1885 book, Hunting Trips of a Ranchman, Teddy Roosevelt, was posed like a rugged, anachronistic hunter from the previous century in a buckskin suit. He can rehabilitate himself more as a cowboy, a gunslinger, a hardened frontiers man. T.R. was very proud of the fact that he was born frail and weak in the lap of luxury in New York City, but by his own will had vigorously turned himself into a broad-chested, strapping young man
罗斯福小时候是个体弱多病的孩子。他声音尖细，人们嘲笑他。克里斯汀·霍根是伊利诺伊大学的历史学教授。我认为这有助于解释他为什么去达科他州成为一名牧场主，对吧？在他1885年的书《牧场主的狩猎旅行》封面上，泰迪·罗斯福摆出了一个来自上个世纪的粗犷、不合时宜的猎人姿势，穿着鹿皮套装。他可以把自己重塑为牛仔、枪手、坚毅的边疆人。T.R.非常自豪，他出生在纽约市奢华的环境中，身体虚弱，但他凭自己的意志，通过每天的训练和过艰苦的生活，把自己变成了一个胸膛宽阔、身材魁梧的年轻人，
by training every day and subjecting himself to the strenuous life just in time for this era of perceived peace in East Coast America. So the rise of white-collar work, the move from a farm economy, a more rural economy to a more urban economy. and more and more middle-class men are sitting at desk, doing desk jobs instead of strenuous labor. Oh, no, feared Roosevelt. There were fewer and fewer opportunities for men to lead the strenuous life.
正好赶上了美国东海岸这个所谓的和平时代。随着白领工作的兴起，从农业经济、更偏向农村的经济向更城市化的经济转变，越来越多的中产阶级男性坐在办公桌前做文职工作，而不是从事艰苦的体力劳动。哦，不，罗斯福担心。男性过艰苦生活的机会越来越少了。
And then if you remember your high school history, the closing of the frontier in the 1890s, so that led to a lot of anxiety again among the same class of white, wealthier men that they wouldn't have the potential to test their metal. And at the very end of that year, December 29th, 1890,
如果你还记得高中历史，1890年代边疆的关闭，这再次导致了同样阶层的白人、较富裕男性之间的焦虑，担心他们没有潜力来考验自己的勇气。而在那一年年底，1890年12月29日，
The United States soldiers of the 7th Cavalry murdered hundreds of Lakota men, women, and children in South Dakota. This was the Wounded Knee Massacre, and it was among the last major battles of the Indian Wars. And Roosevelt sees this as a big problem. Roosevelt, he's arguing that it was actually violence between Americans and American Indians that was the furnace that fused the new American race.
美国第七骑兵团的士兵在南达科他州屠杀了数百名拉科塔族的男人、女人和儿童。这就是伤膝河大屠杀，它是印第安战争中最后几次重大战役之一。罗斯福认为这是一个大问题。罗斯福认为，正是美国人和美国印第安人之间的暴力，才是熔炼出新美国种族的熔炉。
Phil Kly again. The ongoing insubes. Indian wars for Roosevelt had been a source of American identity. It was a way that all kinds of men, rich men, poor men, Irish white or English white, or German white, or Dutch white, could go west, forget their past, fight side by side, and come together as Americans. And once the frontier was closed off, you needed to continue that by having wars in other places. And this was not some kooky personal belief. that Roosevelt had, a lot of men agreed with him. There were a lot of people involved in politics in the time
菲尔·克莱再次提到。对罗斯福来说，持续不断的印第安战争一直是美国身份的源泉。这是一种让各种各样的男人——富人、穷人、爱尔兰裔白人、英裔白人、德裔白人或荷兰裔白人——都能去西部，忘记过去，并肩作战，团结成为美国人的方式。一旦边疆关闭，你就需要通过在其他地方进行战争来延续这一点。这并不是罗斯福个人的古怪信仰，很多男人都同意他的观点。当时有很多参与政治的人
who were really worried about what it would mean to and not have another generation of war-tested men overlooking wars, Indian wars, in the American West. The sense was that there wasn't another generation of men in the United States who would carry on the martial virtues, which were understood as being self-sacrificing, dedication to the nation, heroism, valor, physical toughness. An essay in the Upper Crest Periodical, the Arena, warned,
非常担心没有下一代经历过战争考验的男人会意味着什么。人们认为，美国没有下一代人能够传承尚武美德，这些美德被理解为自我牺牲、对国家的奉献、英雄主义、英勇和身体强健。一份名为《竞技场》的顶级期刊上的一篇文章警告说，
the new danger will be peace rot, peace rot, as if peace were a harmful and terrible thing to be avoided. In peacetime, soldiers were dressed in feathers and pickle helmets just for show. The wealth of the gilded age was drawing attention to class differences. Americans were becoming vain and materialistic, and a feat now, cried the aging veterans of the Civil War on both sides. they waxed nostalgic about the values that war brought, the camaraderie of being out in the field in the company of other men, away from women. That would do men well these days, veterans thought,
新的危险将是“和平腐烂”，仿佛和平是一种应该避免的有害且可怕的事情。在和平时期，士兵们穿着羽毛和尖顶头盔只是为了炫耀。镀金时代的财富引起了人们对阶级差异的关注。内战双方的老兵们大声疾呼，美国人变得虚荣、物质主义且软弱无能。他们怀念战争带来的价值观，怀念在野外与其他男人并肩作战、远离女性的同志情谊。老兵们认为，这对现在的男人有好处，
especially, they looked around. What with all these uppity new women? And so by the new woman, I'm talking about this phenomenon of the 1890s and onward. The so-called new woman did not just stay at home and watch the kids. She was starting to have a life outside the home. She was riding bicycles. She was wearing bloomers. She might even have a college degree or a job.
尤其是当他们环顾四周时。这些傲慢的新女性是怎么回事？所以说到“新女性”，我指的是1890年代及以后的这种现象。所谓的“新女性”不仅仅待在家里看孩子。她开始拥有家庭以外的生活。她骑自行车，穿灯笼裤。她甚至可能有大学学位或工作。
Working class women had always had jobs, but what was new was middle class women were more likely to have jobs. And then women were becoming more active in politics. She might campaign for suffrage. Or if she lived in Utah or other Western states, she might actually be able to vote already. And this is way before the 19th Amendment. That was in 1920.
工人阶级的女性一直都有工作，但新鲜的是中产阶级女性更有可能拥有工作。而且女性在政治上变得更加活跃。她可能会为争取选举权而奔走。或者如果她住在犹他州或其他西部州，她可能已经能够投票了。这远在第19修正案之前，那是1920年的事。
We're talking about the 1890s. And more widely, women were voting in school board and local elections. Not only did these new women make the men with their desk jobs cling even more tightly to their manhood. The new women brought bold, radical ideas into the political sphere, and this was extra terrifying to men. Their once demure, sweet wives had now become opinionated pants wearing and poised for a full world takeover. And the new women, for their part, didn't deny it. Man is morally in his infancy. The woman's rights essayist Sarah Grand wrote in the North American Review.
我们说的是1890年代。更广泛地说，女性在学校董事会和地方选举中投票。这些新女性不仅让那些做文职工作的男人更加紧紧地抓住他们的男子气概，新女性还将大胆、激进的思想带入了政治领域，这让男人们感到格外恐惧。他们曾经端庄、甜美的妻子现在变得固执己见、穿着裤子，准备全面接管世界。而新女性方面，并没有否认这一点。女性权利散文家莎拉·格兰德在《北美评论》中写道，人类在道德上还处于婴儿期。
In this mismanaged world, it looks as if she should soon be obliged to do their work as well as our own, or nothing will be done. A lot of the women activists at the time said, like, we as people can make a better world, right? And this extended period of so-called peace they were living in provided a sort of opening for the new woman. The valorization of force was often used as a justification for keeping women out of politics. The repeated refrain was always, no fight, no vote. Sorry, ladies, you can't vote. You didn't serve your country because you weren't allowed to. But that was the logic.
在这个管理不善的世界里，看起来她很快就不得不做他们的工作以及我们自己的工作，否则什么也做不成。当时很多女性活动家说，作为人，我们可以创造一个更美好的世界，对吧？而她们所处的这段所谓的长期和平时期，为新女性提供了一种契机。对武力的推崇经常被用作将女性排除在政治之外的理由。反复出现的口号总是：“不打仗，没投票权”。抱歉，女士们，你们不能投票。你们没有为国效力，因为你们不被允许。但这就是逻辑。
Voting rests on physical cores. It rests on guns. It rests on the capacity to kill. But here we were coming on 30 years since the Civil War. And the vast majority of this new generation of office workers had grown up without So now what? None of them got to vote? The new women pointed out, aha, this is a flaw in the argument. Maybe war is not as necessary to citizenship as you thought, fellows. And so a lot of women were very excited about a burgeoning movement known as arbitration. In the late 19th century, a movement for international arbitration arose in the United States. And one of the goals of the movement was to end war via treaty arrangements. The arbitration movement argued that we, civilization, had become sophisticated enough to talk through all our problems in lieu of fighting. Admittedly, some of the new women took this idea to the extreme.
投票权建立在身体核心力量之上。它建立在枪支之上。它建立在杀戮的能力之上。但距离内战已经过去30年了。绝大多数这一代新的办公室职员在成长过程中都没有经历过战争。那现在怎么办？他们都不准投票吗？新女性指出，啊哈，这是论点中的一个漏洞。伙计们，也许战争并不像你们想象的那样对公民身份是必要的。因此，许多女性对一场被称为“仲裁”的新兴运动感到非常兴奋。19世纪末，美国兴起了一场国际仲裁运动。该运动的目标之一是通过条约安排结束战争。仲裁运动认为，我们文明已经足够成熟，可以通过谈判解决所有问题，而不是诉诸战争。诚然，一些新女性将这一想法推向了极端。
Frances Willard, the leader of the Women's Christian Temperance Union, proposed that Harvard and Yale canceled their annual football game and use arbitration instead. But generally speaking, arbitration wasn't some pipe dream. The United States took real steps to act on it. And the United States is a starting point on this, negotiated and signed a treaty with Great Britain in 1897. This treaty stated that for the next five years, the United States and Great Britain would not fight, but arbitrate all of their disputes. It was signed by the U.S. Secretary of State and a knighted British diplomat. It was supported by President Grover Cleveland, along with many academics and newspapers, and it seemed like this would be the start of an amazing new era of peace. And then the treaty went to the Senate for ratification and the Senate nixed it.
妇女基督教节制会的领导人弗朗西斯·威拉德提议，哈佛大学和耶鲁大学取消他们的年度橄榄球赛，改用仲裁来解决。但总的来说，仲裁并非白日梦。美国采取了切实步骤来付诸行动。美国作为起点，于1897年与英国谈判并签署了一项条约。该条约规定，在接下来的五年里，美国和英国将不进行战争，而是仲裁双方所有的争端。它由美国国务卿和一位受封爵位的英国外交官签署。它得到了格罗弗·克利夫兰总统以及许多学者和报纸的支持，看起来这将是一个令人惊叹的和平新时代的开始。然后条约被提交给参议院批准，参议院否决了它。
So you might wonder, like, why were they so fearful that there might be peace between the United States and Great Britain? Lawmakers voiced their fear of peace rot, saying, war is healthy to a nation. And a little bloodletting would be an admirably good thing about this time for the people of the United States. They talked about their fears of overdeccadence, of male degeneracy. Theodore Roosevelt at this point had returned to New York from the West and started his political ascent. And Theodore Roosevelt worried that arbitration would produce, and I'm quoting him, a flabby, timid type of character that would eat away the great fighting futures of our race. Arbitration was, in other words, for pussies.
所以你可能会想，为什么他们如此害怕美国和英国之间可能存在和平？立法者表达了他们对“和平腐烂”的恐惧，称战争对一个国家是有益的。对于当时的美国人民来说，一点流血事件将是一件令人钦佩的好事。他们谈论对过度颓废和男性退化的恐惧。西奥多·罗斯福此时已从西部回到纽约，开始了政治崛起。西奥多·罗斯福担心仲裁会产生——我引用他的话——“一种软弱、胆怯的性格，会侵蚀我们种族伟大的战斗未来”。换句话说，仲裁是给懦夫准备的。
And so the movement was seen as a female movement, which is not to say that men were not also supportive of arbitration, But the opponents came to see it as a feminized movement and as a symbol of what was wrong in American politics. In political cartoons, arbitration was personified as a woman, an arbitrationist as ugly, sour-faced hags wearing preposterously proportioned bloomers. And in opposition to it, they would say, we need manhood asserted. And Theodore Roosevelt, who is often the poster child for this, said, I should welcome almost any war for, I think this country needs one. And this country need only look just off our coast down to the east, and there was a poor little colony, struggling for its independence from Spain, and not for the first time. Right. So the third struggle, major struggle for independence broke out in Cuba in 1895. But this time, Americans like Roosevelt were like, we have got to intervene. We have to help Cuba.
因此，这场运动被视为一场女性运动，这并不是说男性不支持仲裁，但反对者开始将其视为一场女性化的运动，并将其视为美国政治中错误事物的象征。在政治漫画中，仲裁被拟人化为女性，仲裁主义者被描绘成穿着比例荒谬的灯笼裤、面容酸楚的泼妇。为了反对它，他们会说，我们需要彰显男子气概。而经常作为这一观点代言人的西奥多·罗斯福说，我欢迎任何战争，因为我认为这个国家需要一场。而这个国家只需要看看我们海岸外向东的地方，那里有一个可怜的小殖民地，正在为从西班牙独立而挣扎，而且这已经不是第一次了。是的，第三次争取独立的重大斗争于1895年在古巴爆发。但这一次，像罗斯福这样的美国人认为，我们必须干预。我们必须帮助古巴。
Cuba, the island, was often represented as a damsel in distress. And notoriously, William Randolph Hearst and all of his papers spilled a lot of ink trying to convince the American public to get involved in Cuba. And in the Bowery in Manhattan, a play about a virtuous Cuban maiden rebuffing the advances of a dastardly Spaniard was presented entirely in Yiddish. So it fit into a literary genre that was super popular, which was a genre of heroic chivalrous knightly men going off in rescuing, There were some Americans who were genuinely very upset by the horrid plight of innocent Cuban civilians who were being rounded up and put into concentration camps. Horrifying the death tolls from that. And there were Americans who were less concerned about that loss of civilian life. There were financial interests.
古巴这个岛屿经常被描绘成处于困境中的少女。众所周知，威廉·伦道夫·赫斯特和他所有的报纸花费了大量笔墨试图说服美国公众介入古巴。在曼哈顿的鲍厄里区，一部关于一位贞洁的古巴少女拒绝卑鄙的西班牙人追求的戏剧完全用意第绪语演出。所以它符合当时非常流行的一种文学类型，即英雄、骑士般的男人去拯救少女的类型。有一些美国人确实对无辜的古巴平民被围捕并关进集中营的悲惨处境感到非常不安。那里的死亡人数令人震惊。也有一些美国人对平民生命的损失不那么关心。存在经济利益。
Especially in the sugar business, many sugar plantations in Cuba were owned by American sugar companies, and they sure wouldn't mind having more control over the island. They were unvocal in advancing their interest in wanting a U.S. intervention for economic reasons. but were potential financial gains or romantic chivalry or even humanitarian aid enough to justify going to fucking war? Arbitrationists didn't think so. I mean, one critic even pointed out, you know, we have lynchings here in our own country, and nobody seems to care about that.
特别是在制糖业方面，古巴的许多糖厂由美国糖业公司拥有，他们当然不介意对该岛有更多的控制权。他们直言不讳地推进自己的利益，出于经济原因希望美国进行干预。但是，潜在的经济收益、浪漫的骑士精神，甚至是人道主义援助，足以证明去打一场该死的战争吗？仲裁主义者不这么认为。我的意思是，一位评论家甚至指出，你知道，我们自己的国家也有私刑，似乎没人关心。
Why are we suddenly so riled up about Cuba? And the president at the time, McKinley, had actually witnessed the civil war. He harbored no romance about how awful battle was, and he refused to listen to the lawmakers who were all but begging him to please, please, please declare war on Spain. His opponents on both sides of the aisle were very critical. They kept saying the United States needs a man in the White House.
为什么我们突然对古巴如此激动？而当时的麦金莱总统实际上亲眼目睹了内战。他对战争的残酷性没有任何浪漫幻想，他拒绝听从那些几乎是在乞求他宣布对西班牙开战的立法者的意见。他在两党的反对者都非常尖刻。他们一直说美国需要一个真正的男人在白宫。
Theodore Roosevelt famously said that McKinley had the backbone of a chocolate declare. But then there was an explosion on an American ship that was docked in Havana. It blew up in the middle of the night and 266 men on board dying. Before we even knew what caused the explosion on the ship, like for all we knew at the time, it could have been an accident, there was outrage. The Senate was like, oh, we have got to go to war now. DePot one congressman, honor comes first, and if an honorable man were insulted, he would not arbitrate. He would fight back.
西奥多·罗斯福曾有名言说麦金莱有“巧克力泡芙的脊梁”。但随后，一艘停泊在哈瓦那的美国军舰发生了爆炸。它在半夜炸毁，船上266人死亡。在我们甚至不知道是什么导致了船上爆炸之前——就像我们当时所知的那样，它可能是一场事故——愤怒爆发了。参议院说，哦，我们现在必须去打仗了。一位国会议员说，荣誉第一，如果一个有荣誉的人受到侮辱，他不会仲裁。他会反击。
McKinley functionally gives in. He punts the decision to declare war to Congress. And, of course, they declare war. They're really amped on it. And then they just rallied around the military, so several members of Congress actually enlisted, others offered to do so. Hundreds of thousands of Americans. American men volunteer to enlist, and they ask to be shipped off to liberate Cuba. Even Teddy Roosevelt leaves his job as assistant naval secretary when the war breaks out,
麦金莱实际上屈服了。他把宣战的决定权推给了国会。当然，他们宣布了战争。他们对此非常兴奋。然后他们就团结在军队周围，所以几位国会议员实际上应征入伍，其他人也主动提出这样做。成千上万的美国人。美国男人志愿入伍，他们要求被派往解放古巴。甚至泰迪·罗斯福在战争爆发时也辞去了海军助理部长的职务，
and he gets in on the action in Cuba. He leads the first volunteer cavalry, known as the Rough Riders. Teddy Roosevelt, when he went to Cuba with the Rough Riders, he worked out the actual ethnic composition of his unit. Phil Kly says the Rough Riders were going to go off to Cuba together, and they were going to fight side by side and fuse the great American race. just like how Roosevelt thought the Indian wars once had. So among the rough riders, there were lower-class men, middle-class men, upper-class men,
他参与了古巴的行动。他领导了第一志愿骑兵团，被称为“粗犷骑士”。泰迪·罗斯福在和“粗犷骑士”去古巴时，他制定了部队的实际种族构成。菲尔·克莱说，“粗犷骑士”要一起去古巴，他们要并肩作战，熔炼伟大的美国种族。就像罗斯福认为印第安战争曾经做过的那样。所以，在“粗犷骑士”中，有下层阶级的男人、中产阶级的男人、上层阶级的男人，
and men of a number of different races. So they'd have the right number of Anglo-Saxons, the right number of American Indians, the right number of Irishmen, and then they'd all go and be fused into one kind of new American race in the cauldron where the heat is provided by war. So Roosevelt leads this Benetton ad into victory at San Juan Hill. although he makes it sound like they single-handedly liberated Cuba. Little Roosevelt would have you believe that they played a major role because he was a massive self-promoter. For the rest of his life, Teddy Roosevelt also went by Colonel and completely minimized the help he got from the battalion of black soldiers known as the Buffalo soldiers, who were also there at San Juan Hill.
以及许多不同种族的男人。所以他们会有合适数量的盎格鲁-撒克逊人、合适数量的美国印第安人、合适数量的爱尔兰人，然后他们都会去，并在战争提供的热量熔炉中被融合成为一种新的美国种族。所以罗斯福带领这个“贝纳通广告”般的部队在圣胡安山取得了胜利。尽管他让它听起来像是他们单枪匹马解放了古巴。小罗斯福会让你相信他们发挥了主要作用，因为他是一个巨大的自我推销者。在余生中，泰迪·罗斯福也以“上校”自称，并完全淡化了他从被称为“水牛士兵”的黑人营那里得到的帮助，他们当时也在圣胡安山。
I would say the significance of that battle was making Roosevelt into a war hero that helped launch his political career. Roosevelt wore his wide-brimmed cowboy-looking Rough Riders hat to the 1900 Republican Convention, and there he was hailed as the heroic fighter and the fighting Republican. It led to a new generation of military heroes. It rehabilitated the upper crust, Harvard-educated white-collar, theater Roosevelt-type. This model, man is people who deserve political leadership and who working-class men could relate to more because they had served in the military. It was there at that 1900 convention where Roosevelt was nominated to be the vice president to McKinley, who, I guess, forgave that whole chocolate-y-clair insult.
我会说那场战役的意义在于让罗斯福成为了战争英雄，这有助于开启他的政治生涯。罗斯福在1900年共和党全国代表大会上戴着他那顶宽檐、看起来像牛仔的“粗犷骑士”帽子，在那里他被誉为英雄战士和战斗的共和党人。它引领了新一代的军事英雄。它重塑了上层阶级、哈佛毕业、白领、泰迪·罗斯福类型的人。这种模式的男人是值得政治领导地位的人，而且因为他们曾在军队服役，工人阶级的男人更能与他们产生共鸣。正是在那次1900年的大会上，罗斯福被提名为麦金莱的副总统候选人，我想，麦金莱原谅了那个关于“巧克力泡芙”的侮辱。
McKinley was looking for a military hero to run as his running mate and then selected the war hero. Stockmoder, Roosevelt. And then, when McKinley was assassinated in 1901, the fight in Republican became president. And the vibe was like, wasn't that fun, boys? See, I told you we needed a war. the Spanish-American War, which lasted less than a year with relatively few U.S. casualties, was called the Splendid Little War. But the part that Roosevelt didn't talk about so readily is that we'd taken it too far. The splendid little war had morphed into something else.
麦金莱正在寻找一位军事英雄作为竞选搭档，然后选择了战争英雄。罗斯福。然后，当麦金莱在1901年被暗杀时，“战斗的共和党人”成为了总统。当时的气氛就像是，小伙子们，那不是很刺激吗？看，我告诉过你们我们需要一场战争。美西战争持续了不到一年，美国伤亡相对较少，被称为“辉煌的小战争”。但罗斯福没有那么容易谈论的部分是，我们做得太过分了。这场辉煌的小战争已经演变成了别的东西。
The United States had been so excited about finally getting into a big war that we had attacked Spain in as many of their colonies as we could reach. The United States ended up annexing Guam and also taking Puerto Rico, which was a Spanish colony proximate to Cuba, and diddo the annexation of the Philippines. So the U.S. had entered Manila, where extremely long story cut entirely too short, we were suddenly like, oh, we should just take this colony. There were a number of American men, including Theodore Roosevelt, who argued that one of the great things about becoming involved in the Philippines is it would build like a masterful class of colonizing men, right? That it would build manhood among U.S. occupiers. Which is totally bonkers. Ostensibly, the purpose of this whole war was to liberate the people of Cuba, not to go colonize other people. And at the time, a lot of Americans actually raised this point and pointed out that this is kind of against our stated values of democracy and independence.
美国对终于能参加一场大战争感到非常兴奋，以至于我们攻击了西班牙在我们可以到达的尽可能多的殖民地。美国最终吞并了关岛，还占领了波多黎各（古巴附近的一个西班牙殖民地），并吞并了菲律宾。所以美国进入了马尼拉，长话短说，我们突然觉得，哦，我们应该直接占领这个殖民地。包括西奥多·罗斯福在内的许多美国人认为，参与菲律宾事务的一大好处是它会建立一种像“殖民大师”一样的阶层，对吧？它会在美国占领者中建立男子气概。这简直太疯狂了。表面上，这场战争的目的是解放古巴人民，而不是去殖民其他人。当时，许多美国人实际上提出了这一点，并指出这在某种程度上违背了我们所宣称的民主和独立价值观。
And yet, here we were, trying to take over the Philippines. The war became a long, horrible, drawn-out, bloody guerrilla war. The United States resorted to torture. We had entered this war to be the great knight, the savior of the damsel in distress, Cuba. And we had become the villain, the monstrous. torture of the Philippines. Soldiers returning from the Philippines reported on the cruelties
然而，我们却在这里试图接管菲律宾。战争变成了一场漫长、可怕、旷日持久、血腥的游击战。美国诉诸了酷刑。我们参加这场战争是为了成为伟大的骑士，成为处于困境中的少女——古巴的救星。而我们却变成了恶棍，变成了菲律宾的残酷折磨者。从菲律宾回来的士兵报告了
that the U.S. Army was perpetuating. The war went on from 1898 to roughly 1902 when Theodore Roosevelt declared it over. The narrative flipped. It wasn't simply that some bloodletting and a little vigor is good for the boys.
美国军队正在犯下的暴行。战争从1898年一直持续到1902年左右，当时西奥多·罗斯福宣布战争结束。叙事发生了反转。不仅仅是流点血和一点活力对小伙子们有好处。
This war, it seemed, was no longer the right kind of war anymore. Right? It's taking like our fine young men from the farms in Nebraska. and turning them into depraved, diseased, alcoholic killers, right? And so I think that really undercut some of the arguments that war was inherently good for building the old character. That was the bridge into the 20th century.
这场战争，看起来，不再是那种“正确的战争”了。对吧？它把我们内布拉斯加州农场里优秀的年轻人带走，把他们变成了堕落、患病、酗酒的杀手，对吧？所以我认为这确实削弱了一些关于战争本质上对建立旧性格有益的论点。那是通往20世纪的桥梁。
And then it's the 1900s. And Teddy Roosevelt is president and the U.S. has announced its entry onto the global stage. The most territory the United States has ever had was in 1902. This is how we set down roots on the other side of the world. This is how we had control of the Philippines for a long time. This is how we reserved Guantanamo Bay. This is how we have Guam and Puerto Rico.
然后是1900年代。泰迪·罗斯福是总统，美国宣布进入全球舞台。美国拥有的领土最多的时候是在1902年。这就是我们在世界另一端扎根的方式。这就是我们长期控制菲律宾的方式。这就是我们保留关塔那摩湾的方式。这就是我们拥有关岛和波多黎各的方式。
This is how we went from the edge of arbitration to the other extreme. We showed world powers that we don't need a lot of provocation to get involved in other countries' issues. So it is sort of the roots of like America world police. Significant roots. But to bring all this back to close. The Spanish-American War made a significant change to the American military uniform. You can see the shift in style in Theodore Roosevelt's Rough Rider uniform, which is there on display in the house that is landmarked as his birthplace.
这就是我们从仲裁的边缘走向另一个极端的方式。我们向世界大国展示，我们不需要太多的挑衅就会介入其他国家的问题。所以这算是“美国世界警察”的根源。重要的根源。但要把这一切总结起来。美西战争对美国军装产生了重大改变。你可以在西奥多·罗斯福的“粗犷骑士”制服中看到风格的转变，那套制服就在他出生地地标建筑中展出。
But here we are looking at the Rough Rider hat, jacket, his bandana, and his set of gloves that he wore in the Spanish-American War. Alyssa Parker Geisman with the National Park Service met up with me after my tour of Teddy Roosevelt's birthplace to make sure I saw Roosevelt's Rough Rider suit. So the Rough Rider uniform as an officer, TR would be responsible for providing and paying for his own uniform. Roosevelt's uniform made by Brooks Brothers is constructed of the same khaki-colored canvas material that was used for the enlisted men's uniforms. So yes, it's pretty cool that this safari-looking suit was made by Brooks Brothers. I love that. But this war, the Spanish-American War, is the war where the U.S. military sheds its signature blue.
但我们现在看到的是“粗犷骑士”的帽子、夹克、他的头巾，以及他在美西战争中戴的一副手套。国家公园管理局的艾丽莎·帕克·盖斯曼在我参观完泰迪·罗斯福出生地后与我见面，确保我看到了罗斯福的“粗犷骑士”套装。所以作为一名军官，“粗犷骑士”制服，TR有责任提供并支付他自己的制服费用。罗斯福的制服由布鲁克斯兄弟制作，采用与士兵制服相同的卡其色帆布材料制成。所以是的，这套看起来像狩猎装的制服是由布鲁克斯兄弟制作的，这很酷。我喜欢这一点。但这场战争，美西战争，是美国军队脱掉其标志性蓝色制服的战争。
Instead of copying the jaunty French or the stately Prussians, during our era of colonial ambition, we started to mimic the colonial outfits of the British Empire. Here's Kerner again. Kaki has its origins going back to the British Empire in India as like a summer uniform. When the Spanish-American War first began, American enlisted soldiers arrived to those various Spanish colonies
在我们的殖民野心时代，我们没有模仿轻快的法国人或庄严的普鲁士人，而是开始模仿大英帝国的殖民服装。克纳又来了。卡其布起源于大英帝国在印度的夏季制服。当美西战争刚开始时，美国士兵到达那些不同的西班牙殖民地时，
in their blue sack coats, those blue flannel coats with the gold buttons they had worn in the Civil War. And in the heat of Cuba, where the son of the Philippines, they took their jackets off. So they buy and get a lot of these khaki cotton uniforms direct from like Singapore in India
穿着他们在内战中穿的那种蓝色麻袋外套，那种带有金色纽扣的蓝色法兰绒外套。在古巴的炎热中，在菲律宾的太阳下，他们脱掉了夹克。所以他们直接从新加坡和印度购买并获得了许多这种卡其色棉质制服，
to issue to officers in the Philippines. Officers like Teddy Roosevelt got their khakis custom-made or fitted for them. And British khaki had a color that looks a lot like what Americans would now call olive green. And they're like, man, not only is this more comfortable, we're harder to see. The battlefield had a new problem, visibility. All the wars before had been very, very smoky. And then with the introduction of smokeless powder, you no longer had this occluding, smoke on the battlefield, which makes everybody easier to see.
发给菲律宾的军官。像泰迪·罗斯福这样的军官让他们的卡其布制服定制或合身。英国卡其布的颜色看起来很像美国人现在所说的橄榄绿。他们觉得，伙计，这不仅更舒服，我们还更难被发现。战场有一个新问题：可见度。之前所有的战争都非常、非常烟雾缭绕。然后随着无烟火药的引入，战场上不再有那种遮挡视线的烟雾，这使得每个人都更容易被看到。
So you're a more visible target, and what's worse, the guns are better. What ends up happening over the course of 19th century is the introduction of rifle weapons that are easily reloadable. Which means the average infantryman is more dangerous. Which necessitates these skirmish tactics where you're getting further and further apart. After the Spanish-American War, in the dawn of the 20th century, America looks at the ways that war is trending. They take stock of their own experiences,
所以你是一个更显眼的目标，更糟糕的是，枪支更好了。19世纪发生的事情是引入了易于重新装填的步枪武器。这意味着普通步兵更危险了。这就需要这些散兵战术，让你离得越来越远。美西战争后，在20世纪初，美国审视了战争的趋势。他们总结了自己的经验，
fighting in other climates, having to go long distances to foreign lands. And in August of 1904, the United States Army officially adopts olive green drab. It's just a better color for blending in with the environment. And if we were going to keep fighting exotic new wars
在不同的气候中战斗，必须长途跋涉到外国土地。1904年8月，美国陆军正式采用橄榄绿。这是一种与环境融合更好的颜色。如果我们还要继续打异国情调的新战争，
in exotic new countries, uniforms should fit specific tactical and climate needs. right? And so, the quartermaster reasoned, they should take a look at the methods and techniques and tips that were emerging from a new kind of business in America, the outdoor industry. But that's next chapter.
在异国情调的新国家，制服应该符合特定的战术和气候需求，对吧？所以，军需官推断，他们应该看看美国一种新兴商业——户外产业——中出现的方法、技术和技巧。但那是下一章的内容。
Articles of interest is reported, produced, cut, and performed by Avery Truffleman, who is me, but I have a lot of guardrails on these things. Alison Berringer listens to my drafts, edits my scripts, and makes them make sense. Then I send my drafts to journalist and costume historian Charles McFarlane, who knows a lot about the military. Then I send the scripts to a fact-checker, Yasmin al-Sahad, who goes through and asks questions like, do bowhead whales live to 250 years old? Then, after I add music, which is by Ray Royal with theme songs by Sasami, I send it to Jocelyn Gonzalez, an engineer at PRX, who mastered and mixed it. And thank you so much to Angel Ellis, an iconic journalist in her own right, who I can't. can't believe listen to this. Thanks as well to Audrey Mardovich and the whole team at Radiotopia.
《感兴趣的文章》由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼报道、制作、剪辑和表演，也就是我，但我对这些事情有很多限制。艾莉森·贝林格听我的草稿，编辑我的脚本，并使它们合乎逻辑。然后我把草稿发给记者和服装历史学家查尔斯·麦克法兰，他非常了解军事。然后我把脚本发给事实核查员亚斯敏·阿尔-萨哈德，她会仔细检查并提出问题，比如，弓头鲸能活到250岁吗？然后，在我添加音乐（由雷·罗亚尔创作，主题曲由萨萨米创作）之后，我把它发给PRX的工程师乔斯林·冈萨雷斯，她进行了母带处理和混音。非常感谢安吉尔·埃利斯，她本身就是一位标志性的记者，我简直不敢相信她听了这个。也感谢奥黛丽·马多维奇和Radiotopia的整个团队。
I could not make this work without Radiotopia. I also could not make this work without Drew helped. To see images of Teddy Roosevelt's Rough Rider outfit and just a little bit of Buck Mason's Militaria collection, go to articles of interest.substack.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
没有Radiotopia，我无法完成这项工作。没有德鲁的帮助，我也无法完成这项工作。要查看泰迪·罗斯福“粗犷骑士”套装的照片以及一点点巴克·梅森的军事收藏，请访问 articles of interest.substack.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。